78 tours spécial musique donc vous
l'avez compris et nous poursuivons avec
vous bixente et vous allez mettre la
lumière sur un artiste en particulier
grand écart musical on quitte la variété
française c'est ça aujourd'hui je suis
venu par les bras puisque quand on parle
de rap dans les yvelines on a
l'impression que soit on a plus de 25
ans et on connaît la fouine expression
directe soit on a regardé la série
validé récemment et on connaît bosch et
l'attique et si on a beaucoup plus que
25 ans là dans ce cas je
le rappelle une note c'est bien sûr ça
mais ccc gros monuments ses artistes
populaires dire aujourd'hui mais c'est
aussi une véritable passion que de
nombreux habitants font vivre au
quotidien c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas 93
empire comme nos voisins de
seine-saint-denis booba dans les
hauts-de-seine et tous les chanteurs qui
produit mais on a aussi des talents par
exemple un saint quentinois conçu ici
atv 78 cartes à écouter sur
attends grands
ebay
[Musique]
c'est lui
bien
[Musique]
être un grand artiste vu et écouté c'est
le rêve de ce jeune rappeur qui s'est
lancé dans les textes quand il était au
collège il ya plus de dix ans pourquoi
je vous en parle aujourd'hui parce
qu'ils travaillent sans label 100
producteurs et qu'il a eu deux échéances
importantes récemment la première partie
de kery james attrape le 3 décembre
dernier et les landes le lendemain son
premier concert à montigny le bretonneux
là c'était montre mes pensées en
m'habiller tri avec mes deux premières
parties sts à la salle jacques-brel 300
350 personnes c'était complet c'était
vraiment magnifique ça c'est vraiment
une consécration énorme pour moi parce
que ça fait des années que je disais
tout à l'heure voilà l'âge de 10 ans
pour en arriver à ce fameux jour où j'ai
pu partager avec mon public
alors que retailles là une source
d'inspiration qui me parle un petit peu
plus kery james et sa piste de ma
génération actuellement le rap conscient
il veut dénoncer ce qui ne va pas et
véhiculer des messages positifs l'année
dernière par exemple il a sorti un clip
appelé trappe pour nuancer ce qui était
dit dans la ville dans certains médias
regardez une habitante de trappes
m'appelant des instruments que tu fasses
un morceau sur trappe parce que quand tu
as côtoyé cette ville parce que j'ai
étudié là bas et qu'on voit beaucoup de
gens dans les médias parler de cette
ville mais qu'ils la connaissent pas
forcément toi quel est ton point de vue
je dénonce certaines choses parce qu'il
ya des choses qui vont passer c'est une
évidence mais aussi le côté espoir et et
tout côté hbos qui a dans dans les
villes plus populaires alors le rap
conscient avec avec donc curtin mais il
y en a d'autres qui véhiculent d'autres
messages aussi dans les yvelines oui
exactement il ya tout c'est ce qui fait
la force du département aujourd'hui
comme on a vu dans le sujet juste avant
les rappeurs qui ressorte c'est atik
bosch et même 47 terre mais quand on se
penche de plus près sur le prisme
yvelinois du rap il ya tellement
d'autres artistes didier à poissy et son
débit rapide un autre qui a émergé
récemment avec le projet clasico
organisé niax on peut penser aussi à
escales j'ai le duo saint quentinois qui
avait fait parlé avec leçon case à des
poubelles et je ne prends pas le temps
de parler de tous les autres rappeurs
des quartiers qui travaillent dur au
quotidien pour raconter leur histoire
réaliser leur rêve à l'image de kurt à
ce sera d'ailleurs à coeur tac je
laisserai le dernier mot de la chronique
et son avis sur le rassure le rap actuel
dans les yvelines je trouve qu'il a un
corps qu'il ya un corps comment dire
timide et le 78 c'est un énorme
département avec d'énormes ressources et
je pense qu'il ya énormément de talent
et quand on voit certains départements
comme le 94 le 93 tous les autres en
fait il ya énormément d'artistes qui
émergent et je pense que nous dans les
prochaines années là on a de quoi faire
parler en tout cas je l'espère merci à
curtat et merci milk sean t